if every call was killing somebody that
didn't go through what would you do well
you wouldn't do what the FCC asked
because the killing would go on
I have Nick Lester with reason TV and
today we're talking with Daniel
Berninger he is a former principal at
itxc
an early VoIP system as well as vonage
the probably the best non VoIP system
he's now working at vcx e which is
trying to accomplish a transition from
old telephone lines to IP only all IP
network ok we are talking today about
the second dumbest thing that the FCC
has gotten involved in lately and it's
not title 2 for the internet it is
something called RCC or rural call
completion what is that and why should
we be worried about right so rural call
completion is a FCC order trying to
address complaints in rural areas that
people are not getting calls and so if
you think about the telephone network
what it does is complete calls you know
when you say a car what does it do it
moves forward call completion is what
the telephone network does and so people
are and and and should be concerned that
all those calls get completed and this
is you know the FCC has a technical
definition for what what counts as a
rural call right we'll say it's
somewhere out where there aren't many
people right I tends to be on older
lines and people using old dial-up
service as opposed to VoIP or anything
like that right anyway a sizable number
of calls or a certain number of calls
aren't getting threatened yeah okay so
we don't know how many we've had
complaints but one of the issues is that
we haven't quantified how big it is but
in looking into this the FCC a couple of
years ago they ended up having a couple
of dissent decrees against companies
like windstream at level 3 saying you
guys aren't doing enough you've got to
pay a fine right and try and make a
better have better completion rates
right so the RCC
order comes out and what what is the FCC
saying that telephone right so the FCC
did investigations three or four
investigations and find companies and
they said well this is taking too long
so can we automate this process and so
what they've asked is all telephone
companies literally whether you're Skype
or Verizon AT&T all companies in the
United States of America to report on a
quarterly basis whether or not their
calls are completed Oh trillion calls
okay and it's it's about a trillion
calls okay I don't think it's more than
a trillion it may be 925 billion right
and I wait for arguments and what
they're saying is that your call
completion rate if you're a telephone
company of to rural numbers has to be
within 2% of your average call
completion rate right otherwise
otherwise you have to do an
investigation and you get fined etc so
part of the issue here is that the
original investigations were triggered
by complaints you know a customer
believes they're not getting a phone
call that triggers complaint the problem
with the order is that the FCC didn't
like waiting for complaints and so
they're actually trying to use this data
collection to find problems and there's
a bit of a problem there because the
data there's not enough information in
the data for them to find problems and
it's also now what this means is that
the FCC is going to be compiling massive
amounts of metadata essentially the same
stuff that kind of freaked people out
when the NSA was doing it right so the
the FTC will have rules or has rules
about the carrier's to collect that data
and then to aggregate it and report
summaries to the FCC on a quarterly
basis you know what's the harm in just
having the FCC say hey you know what
just you're keeping records somewhere
anyway just give them to us right so a
couple of things one is that the data
that the FCC gets just won't mean
anything they won't be able to extract
problems so if you think about the
telephone network it's this huge
physical system it's sort of a fabric
that covers the planet there are alarms
and systems in there that sort of
identifies problems but those alarms and
systems are
real time meant for you know the 10,000
staff that are sitting there staring at
the screens all the time to detect
problems so when when you don't get a
call you're really upset but that event
one event again among the trillion is
pretty quiet pretty a silent event
inside the network so finding the
problem is very difficult and the FCC
recognized that so instead of actually
finding the problems inside the network
what they've asked for is tell us about
all your successful calls okay and they
think they can extrapolate from this
number of successful calls that's
differential between rural and non-rural
something and and there is no
information there in terms of that they
can say well that's a problem and that's
not a problem and so the harm is a great
deal of effort for no solution so I
guess the the metaphor I use if every
call was killing somebody that didn't go
through what would you do well you
wouldn't do what the FCC asked because
the killing would go on and there was
just there's no value is the FCC facing
a kind of existential crisis you know
it's a very old agency it's been around
you know for decades now I know it was
designed to do things like you know keep
the telephone company when they
basically only allowed one to run the
country in line do you think that
they're doing stuff like this in order
to kind of extend their legitimacy into
the 21st century well in the sense that
they want to have a role and they they
want to sort of assert themselves the
problem is no one's evaluating exactly
what their contribution is basically
their existence is justified by this a
theory that government would be useful
here alright so if you get to the point
where you say I have a telephone network
run by a bunch of companies and the
government would be useful here that's
as far as we've gotten how everybody
actually sort of evaluates okay what is
the contribution of the government what
how would companies absent this kind of
order or this kind of ongoing
investigation really how would they
address this and do they have any
incentive to actually they do in the
sense that we roll call completion is
not really rural call completions call
completion in general
and you and I using the telephone our
sense of the reliability of that device
is essential in terms of us buying that
service and so it's the in the incentive
of all the carrier's to make sure call
completion is as high as it can be and
you know and so as these issues are
raised people would like to solve this
problem so does that I mean but then
does that explain why level 3 or other
carriers were I mean were they having
very bad completion rates I mean did
they deserve to get it right so so the
question is sort of two things one is
they're like a technical glitch or a
switch problem that would cause call
completion rates to decline the
presumption is that there's actors
inside the network that are deciding not
to complete certain calls because
they're relatively more expensive and
that's into rural areas and so the sense
is well let's go find those bad actors
and in some cases just for random
reasons the FCC asked for some data from
a particular carrier they notice that oh
well your call answer rates into this
rural area are not super high let's go
study that some more so from the moment
of complaint and as you dig in maybe you
can find a problem okay but the problem
again with the FCC coming from they're
from complaint to investigation
to just collect everything they go off
the rails tell us a little bit about
vcxo yeah what you know the the dream is
to move from a kind of hybrid system of
old-style telephone lines and switches
to an all IP system what's the great
benefit of that and then who are your
funders sure sure so I started at Bell
Laboratories in 99 91 and I the first
day at the office I said what we're
gonna transform communications I mean
we're just gonna change the world well
it didn't quite happen it turns out that
the telephone network as it exists was
sort of invulnerable to innovation it
just did a voice call and and if you
wanted to say do fax you needed to turn
the fax into a voice call if you want to
do data you got to turn data into a
voice call it just did voice calls well
come around 1995 when the internet and
the IP network showed up you now have a
new network that can do everything and
so what's happened
since then is that Network has kind of
washed away the old Network and so now
we have a communication network that can
do everything the problem is we haven't
been able to turn off that old network
and so that's so VC X is trying to
coordinate between the operators being
able to turn off and shut down that old
network now the win is that we get a
communication system like the Internet
where every telephone call you make
becomes high definition it becomes sort
of leaderless no matter where you're
calling on the planet so on the other
side of this process we get voice calls
like we have internet where you go to a
web site in New Zealand you just don't
care well where everyone connected to
this new network will have
high-definition meter las' voice calls
and shrink the world and my funders and
this are the usual suspects so AT&T
Verizon Comcast some of the smaller
players uma which is a voit player and
everybody we're kind of stuck in the
middle of the river at this point policy
is now just turned back to sort of the
1934 policy for the new network and so
we'll have to see how it plays out but
the technology is rushing ahead we're
waiting for the policy to catch catch
all right we'll leave it there we've
been talking with Dan Berninger of VC XE
about the rural call completion order or
RC C which is the FCC's second biggest
mistake that it's made recently for
reason TV I'm Nikolas